karate kicking jesus time traveling
rollerbladers and whatever the hell this
is
doom patrol season 2 is here with a new
home on hbo max and if you haven't heard
the news
episode 9 wasn't originally supposed to
be the season finale because of covid
they didn't get to film
all of the final episode so if it felt a
bit like this wasn't a finale
that's probably why either way we're
going to take a deep dive into this
finale and try to answer some of its
biggest questions
like who this mystery alter ego is why
niles had a syringe on him and of course
dorothy in the candlemaker but before we
get ready to party make sure to like and
subscribe
lexmantello demands it the final episode
focuses on crazy jane
or should i say miranda who has taken
control of kaye's body as the primary
think of the primary as the captain of
k's
alter egos and part of jane's arc this
season was all about letting go
and accepting miranda as the best person
to handle kay's protection
you were so much stronger than i would
have ever been from now on i'll fall in
line
of course that's right before she's
pushed down the well to drown for all
eternity
as we find out in arguably the biggest
twist of the season
miranda isn't miranda at all in fact the
real miranda died down the well
decades ago so who is this mystery woman
who has
infiltrated k's alter egos my theory is
that it's the candle maker manifesting a
version of
k's abusive father in the last episode
we saw how vic
rita and cliff all faced off against
their quote unquote imaginary friends
but
really it was all the candle makers
doing who's to say that the candle maker
isn't controlling this alter ego somehow
let's remember
that this fake miranda first appeared
after the candle maker made it into the
underground and killed baby doll and
flaming katie that's
one hell of a coincidence if it turns
out the candle maker isn't in control
and of course the candle maker would use
kaye's biggest trauma
the abuse of her father against her and
what better way to infiltrate kay's body
and personalities than by
manifesting as the alter ego the
protector
who stood up to that abusive father told
you i don't want to hear none of that
miranda crap no more
what i'm trying to say here is that this
alter ego is a version of her father
controlled by the candle maker and we
definitely know there's some father
elements by what the fake miranda
says here then who are you
sweet baby that line sweet baby is what
her father used to call her as a child
and if you go all the way back to season
1 episode 9 where
jane confronts her father it's on full
display
sweet sweet baby cake sweet sweet baby
sweet sweet baby but all this really
doesn't matter because kay's body is
completely covered in wax it doesn't
matter who's in control if there's no
body to control in the first place
here's where things get a little more
interesting it's behind me isn't it
the only person who is still standing at
the end of the episode
and yes that's a terrible terrible pun
is niles calder and i think the key to
what happens next lies in this very
quick shot of niles holding a syringe
obviously this will come into play he
wouldn't just randomly bring a syringe
to a carnival with his daughter
unless he planned on using it perhaps on
her now
what's in it my best guess is that it's
the same serum used to suppress
crazy jane's powers the concoction that
was put together by joshua clay in
season 1
that niles said this season is all gone
so who would he use it on doesn't really
make sense
to use it on himself and dorothy's
already gone with the candle maker so
maybe he'll have to use it on jane to
suppress the candle maker taking over
her body there are also two wild cards
out there that could possibly play a
role in what happens next
the first is mr nobody all we know about
him this season is that he's made it out
of the painting and
unavailable because he's working on the
harley quinn animated series
this is just a fun nod to the actor who
plays mr nobody alan tudyk i hope i'm
saying that right
voicing one of the characters on that
show did you just call me a fudger
mr nobody is insanely powerful and
there's no way he'd want the world to
end so it's definitely possible we'll
see him return to join forces with the
doom patrol the second wild card is
danny the brick who we last saw turn
into a tire at the end of episode 4. now
in the comics he later turns into danny
the ambulance and perhaps that tire is
hinting at what he's going to turn into
and the doom patrol
does look like it could use an ambulance
right about now and if dany arrives so
too will the dany zinns like flex
mantello
who can make things appear out of thin
air probably a good thing to have in
this situation
as things look increasingly grim for the
doom patrol it seems their only hope is
dorothy who
at the end of the season goes to take on
the candle maker by herself something
niles says
she isn't ready for in fact dorothy's
character arc is all about growing up
she's actually 103 quarter years old but
is in the body of an 11 year old this
slow growth
niles attributes to her being the
daughter of slava an immortal survivor
of an ancient tribe and slava's
reappearance near the end of the season
indicates her
and likely her people have something to
do with the candle maker slava wants
dorothy to grow up and fight him almost
as if it's some sort of ritual
bringing her into womanhood and bonus
points if you clock the boots she puts
on are ruby color
just like dorothy's ruby slippers in the
wizard of oz
will those boots like dorothy's and oz
be her way back to the real world
and that brings us to who the candle
maker really is
in the comics he's an extra dimensional
being that is the physical
representation of fear such as world war
3
or nuclear bombs he wasn't a threat
because he couldn't travel to the
physical world but he's now found a way
through dorothy's power of making
imaginary creatures come to life
as witnessed throughout the season the
candle maker can grant wishes but these
wishes come at great expense which is
why nyle says she must never make a wish
in the comics the candlemaker allows
three wishes kind of like a genie
and it just so happens she uses her
final wish to bring back
joshua clay one of the murder doom
patrol members add that to the list of
reasons we may see him again
upon using her final wish the
candlemaker gets its freedom into the
physical world
which is what dorothy is wanting to stop
now i don't think the candlemaker is
going to kill dorothy
he needs dorothy in order to get into
the physical world her power
is what makes it possible for him to
live but i do want to talk about the
candlemaker's last
line where he tells dorothy it's time
for her to meet her fate does he know
what she'll become
what she'll be responsible for will he
even try to sway her against niles and
the doom patrol
after all it was niles who kept her
hidden away on dany street for decades
almost like a prisoner now i also see
the show introducing a time travel
element and there are some clues that
hint towards this
time has played a huge role this season
nice wants to slow down dorothy growing
up and wears a longevity talisman
something he trades to willoughby
kipling in order to return the doom
patrol members to their natural size
there's also an interesting episode
where rita and cliff have to take on a
dr
time who controls a rare time bending
element called
continuinium not to mention how the show
utilizes countless flashbacks but it's
the fact cliff won't be able to make his
daughter clara's wedding that leads me
to believe time travel might just happen
i mean it would be the perfect ending if
a time travel element were introduced
and cliff and the doom patrol are both
able to save the day
and he's able to go to his daughter's
wedding we also have larry's interesting
meeting with moscow a space traveler who
like him
also went into that field of energy that
irradiated his body but unlike him she
has learned to control the energy
become one with it and was able to do
this in five years
it's been decades for larry so did time
play a factor here we know how time and
space can be funky like
did you even see interstellar and is
this a hint that we'll soon see a more
normal looking version of larry doom
patrol's character arcs are what set
apart this show from most of the other
superhero shows and movies out there
these characters are well
developed with rich flaws that they have
to overcome rita has to believe that she
isn't a fraud and overcome the trauma of
watching her mom bang a producer larry
tries to rekindle his relationship with
his family only to be backstabbed by
those he loves
vic tries to navigate his own trauma and
falls in love with a woman with a
murderous past
and cliff tries to be the father his
father never was
it's really interesting to watch these
characters grow and how their traumas
inform their decisions but one main
thread that ties all these characters
together
is family all of them have either hurt
or have been hurt by their real families
so much so that the doom patrol itself
becomes a pseudo family
they're all that they've got and i think
that's part of the reason why we care
about them so much we've seen the pain
they've gone through and we want to see
them succeed and i know that i will be
in pain if there isn't a season three
so i hope you'll give this video a like
and subscribe and comment below your
thoughts and theories for next season
you can also follow me on twitter at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much